prise faite par l'équipe Coderre
aux yeux de Luc et Dany acquit
on va parler. Merci beaucoup.
C'est parti pour vrai.
- Tout à fait, ça va être toute
une bataille.
- Pendant les trois thèmes.
Environnement, sécurité et
mobilité. Il y en a un plus
important que l'autre où tout
cela va se mélanger au cours de
la campagne?
- je pense que tous plus que ça,
il y a aussi itinérante, la
sécurité, les finances. Il y a
beaucoup de dossiers je pense
une administration est capable
de gérer tout ça en même temps.
On ne peut pas aller sur un côté
et un ou deux sécurités
actuellement je pense que c'est
le numéro un, priorité pour les
deux candidats, les candidats a
la mairie quelque il soit.
- Et comment vous placez
désavantage les communiants de
ces candidats?
qui par gagnant ou en tout cas
plus loin sous le terme de la
sécurité.
- La sécurité qui par plus
Valérie Plante a cause du des
financements dont ils ont parlé
même si aujourd'hui on n'en
parle plus. Durant les quatre
années, ça n'a pas été la
priorité locale avec la police.
Ça, on le sait de toute façon.
Au niveau de l'équipe Coderre,
je suis un peu biaisé car
j'étais responsable de la
mollesse de mon mandat,
évidemment l'équipe Coderre a
une sensibilité plus grande pour
la sécurité.
- Davantage sur ce thème. Luc,
commentaires généraux d'abord.
C'est quand même le début de la
campagne et sur les thèmes, qui
se démarque?
- Ça va être une campagne
difficile d'abord il y a un
déficit : déficit deux de 170
millions sur trois ans. Alors
les candidats ne peuvent pas
faire de grandes promesses. La
deuxième chose c'est que M.
Coderre ne peut pas beaucoup
accuser son ancien champ fleuri,
la grogne des commerciaux ou une
mauvaise situation économique de
Montréal. Montréal a sentir
beaucoup mieux que d'autres
villes après la pandémie, en
ressort plus rapidement de la
pandémie. Alors ça va être du
tirage de cheveux. Moi, votre
meilleur leader et la critique
de Valérie Plante Waldir vous
vivait dans le passé, tout ce
qui vous désintéresse et de
critiquer. N'a pas le choix de
critiquer, si aucun moment on
doit montrer que la mairesse est
capable de faire son rôle. Sinon
il n'a pas beaucoup de
propositions personnelles.
- Idéologiquement, ces deux
groupes très différents l'un de
l'autre.
- Absolument. On l'a vu avec le
leREV, mais le logement se
convoie le plus. Le nombre de
personnes qui a quitté la ville
a augmenté de 50 %.
On doit considérer au promoteur.
Denis Coderre nous a pas révélé
son plan mais critique le plan
de Valérie Plante en disant ne
pas imposer des règles au
promoteur ne doit pas faire ça,
on doit le développement
économique travail mais on
comprend mal son plan.
- Là-dessus je rajouterai pas te
quelque chose. Faut juste se
rappeler que la première fois
qu'on a eue avec un piquet
directement longtemps pour la
cause des itinérants Notre-Dame
et la réaction de Mme Plante a
été très lente. Il a fallu que
le service de sécurité incendie
lui dise c'est dangereux, il y a
eu un peu, on est obligé
d'évacuer. Faute de quoi le
cabinet serait toujours là
encore. Là-dessus, Mme Plante
d'difficulté a tranché ses
décisions. Ça c'est clair Denis
Coderre a aussi la fâcheuse
façon de décider trop rapidement
sans regarder tout ce qu'il y a
autour. On a deux côtés avec
deux chefs de côté décide vite,
d'autres décident moins vite.
- La mobilité. Est-ce que Madame
Plante a un avantage ou c'est M.
Coderre qui selon vous a un
avantage.
- Les deux ont un énorme
inconvénient. Parce que les
travaux. Les travaux que ce soit
sous Mme Plante Monsieur
Coderre, va être à peu près au
même rythme. Or, ce sont les
travaux qui pénalisent le plus.
Les travaux de la ville center
et les travaux du gouvernement
du Québec. Quatre dans le tunnel
Lafontaine ça veut dire quoi?
ça veut dire quand même deux
voitures qui vont vouloir passer
par Jacques-Cartier. Cette de De
Lorimier sur sa beaucoup sur
Maisonneuve. Dans les deux cas,
n'essaie pas de nous faire
croire que ça va mieux aller
dans les quatre prochaines
années. Cela n'ira pas mieux.
- Là-dessus je te rejoins le Q.
Des deux côtés, faudrait peut-
être que Valérie Plante a avancé
davantage avec les BAS, les
voies sécuritaires dans certains
quartiers. Projet qui avait été
initié par l'administration
Coderre. Les quand même les deux
bourses bataillent pour dire que
c'est mon idée ou mon idée. Ça,
ça me fait du Nasdaq article
projets ont été fait avec les
citoyens, cela n'a pas été
facile mais l'idée a bien fait
son chemin et ça, c'est un beau
projet. Pour le harem, on va en
parler, parce que c'est parti je
pense que c'est un bon succès
parce que les gens se sont
appropriés les rues accordent la
pandémie entre autres.
- Parlons-en du REV réseau
express de vélo sur Bellechasse.
On écoute Madame plante et
Monsieur Coderre, solide de tous
là.
DENIS CODERRE, candidat
à la mairie de Montréal
- On est capable de vivre
ensemble, on n'est pas anti-
vélo, on est pro-mobilité.
Puis on est pro-fluidité. Puis
je remarque qu'il n'y en a pas
beaucoup en passant, qui
passent. Fait que, on est
capable d'en avoir la moitié
puis ça va être en masse.
VALÉRIE PLANTE
chef, Projet Montréal
- Denis Coderre, lui, n'a pas
de problème à détruire des
aménagements sécuritaires, qui
sauvent des vies, pour remettre
des places de stationnement,
et de changer d'idée
dépendamment de la journée.
- Voilà un exemple concret
d'affrontement. Monsieur Canda a
annoncé qu'il allait annoncer
enlever l REV. Est-ce que M.
Coderre en se plaçant petit ami
des autos aussi ne s'est pas
quelque chose d'intéressant
politiquement pour la joute?
- c'est ce qu'il a envoyé un
message a tout Montréal.
Bellechasse, il y a 800 places
de stationnements qui ont été
retirés, il y a 2600 ordinateurs
de vélo par jour. C'est une rue
sur laquelle c'est sur ce banc
d'écoute de maison. La maison ne
fait pas face a la rue dans bien
des cas, c'est le coût de la
maison et les traitements sont
sur les avenues. Alors ce n'est
pas vrai qu'au niveau de cette
piste là il va y avoir beaucoup
de satisfaction se déclare
Monsieur Coderre. Risque d'avoir
beaucoup de satisfaction elle
est celle de la ville en disant
est-ce que le plan vélo et pas
trop agressif sur le projet
Montréal. Ça, c'est vrai. Par
ailleurs, ce depuis hier
beaucoup de gens Montréal avait
des réticences avec une partie
du mandat de Valérie Plante et
n'avaisallé voter. Ça ça va
déchirer le vote.
- Intéressant parce que a
contrario, ce qui fait Coderre
peut envoyer ses retours en
arrière pour le vote un peu plus
progressiste. C'est un calcul
difficile. Comment vous voyez
cela?
- faut comprendre comment ce
projet c'est fait. Il s'était
arrêté, les citoyens n'ont pas
été informés, on ne parlait pas
de stationnement qu'on enlève
toutes sur toute la vie. Après
de mobilité qui peut être
intéressant quand il est très
bien décaissé citoyens. Dans ce
Dans ce projet-là, 300 plaintes
a la ville de Montréal. Notre
dernier rapport en 2020,100 dont
80 parlent du rêve Bellechasse
avec des recommandations Aqsa
été encore des droits et la
stabilité montréalaise. Les
éléments de base n'ont pas été
respectés. Hélas, je pense que
de revenir derrière, de
s'asseoir avec les citoyens, pas
juste des cyclistes, des
résidents qui restent là, les
personnes qui ont perdu leurs
stationnements handicapés, les
vracs n'ont pas le droit sur la
rue, je pense qu'on doit
s'asseoir et de revoir les
priorités. Les fils REV là peut-
être modifiée de ce que tout le
quartier peut en profiter.
-
- Calcul qu'il fait. Moi je
pense que oui.
- Je pense que...
- on ne reprendra pas là-dessus.
- Pour en dépasser stationnement
Leroy c'est moi. Ce consensus.
- Ça s'est fait sans le dire aux
citoyens. L'enquête qui a été
faite c'était clair que les
citoyens ont reçu une lettre
sans leur dire qu'on enlevait
des places de stationnement. Il
en fait pour les vacances de
construction. On a enlevé 822
places. Madelinots est au
complet où les gens rentrent par
là. Une vie.
- On ne démolit pas une rue
quand même des pistes cyclables
là où les stationnement. On ne
peut pas négocier le pays des
familles contre des places de
stationnement.
- Que celle des familles et
celle des familles qui veulent
marcher.
- Les handicapés sont pour les
pistes cyclables.
- Envoi la frontière entre les
deux grandes écoles de pen